what's up cowboy
I mean if you want I can come wire your
house
[Laughter]
very uh very location dependent
uh I'd like to get to the the passport
Bros capabilities but how does one
transition into you know I know there's
no cheat codes but I don't know much
about online marketing and sales I've
been studying looking into it but how do
you get that frying pan to the forehead
moment of uh
I need to take this career and make it
mobile when it is such a location
dependent career what do you do for a
living again electrician
so
you'd have to figure out a way to use
your skills and expertise from anybody
from anywhere in the world so if you're
an electrician for example
um the hell was his name uh
smart passive income was his podcast so
so I used to listen to this podcast like
a couple decades ago it's been around
for a while now maybe it's like 15 years
ago uh Pat Flynn and it was called smart
smart passive income and he used to
interview people all the time and one of
the things that he did was he basically
transitioned to
a media company essentially you know
like creating content like like a
personality and
I think he was in engineering or
something to do with uh
security engineer or something like that
and
he got a package went home just started
doing podcasts and just talking
um usually the the aha moment is okay
well I can't do this anymore because I'm
anchored to a certain location and I
don't have the option to do it anymore
anyway because they packaged me off or
they fired me so I'm going to do
something different I'm going to take my
skills and do something else now
a few of these guys from these podcasts
and Crews
um
entrepreneur on fire was another one uh
John Lee Dumas I think was his name he
moved down to Puerto Rico and you know
again he was location dependent at one
point same thing with you know Pat Flynn
and they created
um you know information business podcast
uh information product and one of the
things I saw Pat Flynn do was he put
this course together that helped uh
people graduate whatever engineering
course that he was an expert in to help
them get that
degree and move forward to the next sort
of uh level because apparently it was
quite difficult so you could put out
information on how to become an
electrician how to get certified DIY
stuff I mean you can do it on YouTube
you know like there's there's there's
YouTube channels like I've had
conversations with other guys in this
space that are also licensed
electricians that do the time for money
thing and it's like there's there's
actually licensed electricians out there
that make YouTube videos and they've got
800 900 000 subs and all they do is they
talk about electrician stuff right you
can do that from anywhere in the world
right
um so you have to get Innovative you
have to sort of lean into Beyond just
okay well I can wire a house okay that's
cool but can you teach I don't know a
million people how to wire a house that
might need to learn how to wire house or
a simplified wiring
um that some random guy in a mud hut in
the middle of nowhere you know can sort
of make for himself like you have to
innovate with it man like you got to
think outside of the box there's inside
of that box thinking there's outside of
the box sync and there's not even seeing
the Box thinking start thinking outside
of the box when you're creating ideas
keep a journal and like jot down ideas
business ideas and see if there's
something that you know really like if
you keep going back to it like you're
journaling and you're writing on these
business ideas and you keep going back
to it over and over and over again
that's a frying pan to the forehead
moment where you're like this might be
something
okay you see what I'm saying like I mean
like you can stumble into these things
just by starting something else but
being intentional and sort of like
thinking about problems that you like
what problems do you see over and over
again as an electrician that you can
solve or sell as an information course
to people that are dealing with the same
problem that
they can sidestep the whole picking up
the Yellow Pages and paying somebody to
come over and do it for them what what
possibilities exist in those Realms the
problem is everywhere is so localized
like your codes in Canada are totally
different than they are here in Missouri
on campus or Florida or go to Europe
they do stuff totally different uh I
specialize in I used to do houses all
the time now all I do is gas stations
and car washes and there's a ton of
money in it
um I can work on the side make forty
fifty thousand dollars
on the side but I have to be there you
can't really teach somebody how to do
that without having the the
the physical apparatus in front of you
you know this is an ice and brusher this
is a top wash this is how you wire it uh
another way to do it Cowboy is you can
you can mash up business ideas like one
of the things that James altiture taught
me a long time ago was Marry up ideas
that you have like passions that you
have
um an example that he's used often is
when you were 12 years old and you kind
of go back to that time what did you do
that you were so passionate about that
you lost track of time doing and is
there a way that you can take a couple
of ideas
marry them up let them have a little bit
of idea sex and turn it into something
like the whole notion of the original
YouTube channel entrepreneurs and cars
was Interview friends and their success
rights for me it was Top Gear meets TED
Talks right
so that's how I sort of like married
those two things up now I still do
videos in the car so I can still call
the CH you know the channel
entrepreneurs and cars because it still
works but you can find different things
that you're passionate about marry them
like I'm I'm always going to love cars
and I'm always going to love hanging out
with entrepreneurs I love having these
conversations and I love driving fast
cars right so I mean I kind of fill that
cup Now by doing rallies because just
about everybody that does the rallies
now and these supercars are almost
always entrepreneurs and they're also
car fans so we we kind of tick off those
boxes you know for each other sort of
thing you just have to sort of like lean
into this stuff man you know what I mean
I'm I'm I'm getting it you know I'm
curious like you said if you were to
move to Dubai you'd be poor so yeah
let's say if you would went to Dubai how
would you how would you get that next
frying pan to the forehead moment like
okay Rich Cooper needs to
do this in Dubai to exponentially make
as much
there as you do here
yeah so I mean Mexico a place like Dubai
is not for me because I like mountains
and beaches right so and it's too far
away from North America like I've still
got anchors here that I that I will come
and visit I don't like traveling and
flying and so for me that would be
a place that I really wouldn't you know
consider I might visit it I might visit
some friends there you know sort of
thing but it's not high up on the list
and also the fact that you really need
serious Bank to live there comfortably
you know what I mean
my problem like say I was going to move
to Mexico the average electrician in
Mexico makes like 13 a day okay so how
do you make what you make where you're
at right now but live in Mexico you have
to create something that's location
independent
right yeah what information can you sell
knowledge past experiences okay or uh
innovative ideas I guess right
and then you need an audience that's
going to buy it so how do you create the
audience you put out a podcast you can
do a YouTube series you can blog there's
only a number of ways to do it but you
have to build the audience so that you
can sell them that thing so while you're
living in Mexico you're making US
dollars at USD rates
right it doesn't have to be Mexico it
could be anywhere you want right you
know whatever you happen to fancy like
it doesn't have to be Dubai it doesn't
have to be Mexico it's like you know
what do you like what kind of food do
you like what kind of women do you like
what kind of landscape do you like do
you like mountains you like beaches you
like dried you like jungle like you know
what's your what's your jam right like
pick that don't don't go where the herds
are going it's like everybody right now
is like Dubai Dubai Dubai Dubai it's
like fine cool
not me
I watched uh your podcast I can't
remember the gentleman's name but he
bought a sailboat at a real successful
uh company and construction company in
California yeah that was uh Dwayne Hale
yeah yeah and I never really figured out
how he was able to take construction
after his divorce in the tournament
mobile
um
trying to remember but he kind of
explained that he he basically just took
his money and bought a 300 400 000
sailboat right I think it's a 53-foot
sailboat
um I'm assuming his boat somewhere
between 300 and half a million right
that's that's the value of a house in
California so he probably just sold his
house bought the boat lives on the boat
does Charters enjoys his life over there
cost of living in the Mediterranean is
cheap he has a good time he's single he
enjoys himself
let's say that would be ideal for me
yeah
yeah right so I mean like you start kind
of leaning into it you'll figure
something out man like you know if
you've got enough hunger for it like if
you have enough strong genuine burning
desire to like go and go and create
something and do something differently
you will find a way you will either find
a way or you will find an excuse right
it's like are you finding a way more
than you're finding an excuse and keep
finding that way right
are you my School of Entrepreneurship
yes sir and the 10 group yeah do those
do those lectures right like
I even went back the other day because
I've recorded the lectures you know well
over a year ago but like do the lectures
again like just just just sit back and
kick through them you know take some
notes key I usually have this um small
notepad it's not with me right now
because I got in the car but I usually
have this like small little uh paper
notepad and I put a pen inside it and I
mean like you can use these things if
you got to report your mileage in your
car you can keep it in your pocket if
you've got business ideas some people
like to use like Evernote as an app on
their phone but just jot down ideas
right like
it's often been said that
creating ideas is like a muscle and if
you don't create ideas if you don't chew
up new ideas then you're going to
atrophy and you're going to lose the
strength you're going to lose its
capabilities and then you're going to be
asking questions like okay well how do I
do this and how it's like nobody's going
to give you the ABCD sort of thing it's
like I think the best thing that you can
do dude is like paint this picture of
what you want your life to look like and
now that you have Clarity on what you
want your life to look like make sure
every day when you get up you do as many
things as possible that get you close to
that goal when you find yourself doing
things that are deviating away from that
goal from that life that you want from
the experiences that you want you're on
the wrong path you have to course
correct you have to re connect to where
it is that you want to go that's what a
painted picture is
yeah or a vivid Vision my old business
coach used to call it a painted picture
and then he changed the name of it to
Vivid Vision he has a book called Vivid
Vision by the way if you want to look it
up Cameron Harold I will I will yeah
that's kind of the NLP process it's it's
just visualizing clear clearly and
concisely what you want and from his
angle what you want your business to
look like what you want your business to
do what problems you want it to solve
what you want the public to view it as
all of those things
um
yeah in the absence of clarity just do
stuff at the end of the day thank you
all right brother see you man I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out